[Music]
Robert Spencer here for jihad watch a
program of the David Horowitz Freedom
Center and for the Center for Security
Policy President Trump first said it
during his inaugural address he said we
will unite the civilized world against
radical Islamic terrorism which we will
eradicate completely from the face of
the earth
president Trump reiterated this the day
after his inauguration when speaking to
the CIA he said we have to get rid of
Isis we have no choice
radical Islamic terrorism and I said it
yesterday has to be eradicated just off
the face of the earth
this is evil this is evil this is a
level of evil that we haven't seen and
you're going to do it and you're going
to do a phenomenal job we're going to
end it it's time it's time right now to
end it
he has since then repeated many times
his determination to eradicate what he
calls radical Islamic terrorism Trump's
words heralded a change that was
momentous and could make all the
difference in our civilizational
struggle against the global jihad this
is because one principal reason why the
threat of Islamic Jihad that confronts
Trump is so large is because his
predecessor largely ignored it denied
its motivating ideology and allowed it
to proliferate a pivotal yet overlooked
action of the Obama administration was
its purge of all mention of Islam and
jihad from law enforcement counter
terror training materials in 2011 to
heed the demand of us Muslim groups and
their allies since then the US has
failed to identify confront and oppose
the ideology that has enabled jihadis to
behave more boldly and aggressively than
ever that ideology has spread unchecked
in the u.s. in large part because Barack
Obama didn't want law enforcement
officials learning about it that would
have been
Islamophobic now it's an adage as old as
warfare itself you cannot defeat an
enemy that you do not understand it
could be added that one certainly has no
chance whatsoever of defeating an enemy
that one refuses to understand yet
Obama's countering violent extremism
program pointedly and ostentatiously
avoided all mention
of Islam and jihad in connection with
terrorism he did this in accord with the
claim that investigating and speaking
honestly about the beliefs and goals of
jihadis would so mortally offend
moderate Muslims that they would become
radicalized and join the jihad
themselves now this whole construct was
absurd those who advance the claim and
they were many never explained why these
moderates who supposedly rejected
violence in the name of Islam as Una's
Lomb ik would be so enraged by
discussion of how others committed
violence in the name of Islam that they
would be moved to violence in the name
of Islam but now the absurd
administration is gone a new age of
realism is dawning strictly speaking it
is impossible within four years or eight
to eradicate radical Islamic terrorism
which is actually Orthodox and
mainstream Islam as long as there are
people who believe that Quran is the
perfect and Eternal Word of Allah
commanding them to wage war against and
subjugate unbelievers there will always
be some believers who get the idea that
they can please Allah and gain a place
in paradise by killing and being killed
for him as the Quran promises in Chapter
9 verse 111 however Trump's declaration
while hyperbolic was a welcome
indication of his apparent determination
to speak honestly about the nature and
magnitude of the jihad threat and to
combat it and roll it back and to call
it evil after eight years of the Obama
administration's moral equivocation and
obfuscation is as refreshing as Ronald
Reagan calling the Soviet Union an evil
empire in the midst of a similar period
of equivocation and cowardice it is
welcome to have that kind of moral
clarity back in the White House
President Trump clearly hopes to emulate
Reagan by destroying the Islamic state
just as Reagan's actions led to the
collapse of the Soviet Union that
collapse of course didn't end communism
which is alive and well in the
Democratic Party in on us University
campuses but it did deal with a
significant blow if Trump ends the
Islamic state it won't end Islamic Jihad
but it will deal it just as significant
a blow after so many years of ignoring
enabling explaining away and blaming
itself for jihad the United States is
finally getting back on track and not a
moment too soon
I'm Robert Spencer
[Music]